Hi, my name is Mary, and I'm from Phoenix
And I wanted to know we're seeing a lot of characters [that] are not from
Storytellers Fairy tales, what is your favorite character that you would like to see from a fictional?
novel
hmm
On the show or just invited chef I got [a] list on the show on the show got it. Oh
I'll start with Oliver twist. Yeah
nixon
Richard Nixon in Storybrooke, no, I don't know about that choice. I call Shenanigans. [okay]? Who's next Colin
[I] want to see the [three] [little] [pigs]
Maybe Indiana Jones, [wow] oh
oh boy
Um I don't I don't know that one yeah
I gosh, I was gonna say
Hans Solo
I was gonna say [starwars] sorry ha ha I think we should have Dora the explorer
What about Annie? tomorrow
Darth vader
Did You say Darth vader. I did say that vader. That's very telling I'm telling you something's changed. Something's changed
Think you have no idea. I [don't] [you] know what no longer okay? Who's next?
Hi, hi. I'm uh my friend wanted me to ask
Your friend your friend wanted you to ask?!! I swear!!
Wanted me to ask how the evil queen coming back is going to impact uh Snow and really
Regina's relationship. well
[the] Evil queen if we remember the one thing she wanted most in the world was snow white's heart, and that will not stop. oooh
But I think that one of [the] things that I really loved in
The course of the five seasons is watching how regina turns to snow and they've really become friends
And I think we're going to see very early on
We're going to see that relationship further and Regina is for the very first time going to have a group of people to [support] her
while her
other half is going to be trying to kill everyone and cause a lot of
mischief yeah
You know the regina [snow] relationship was kind of you know ground zero for the show it started with
Regina breaking of the wedding
and
there's been so much that's happened between them since then that you know it's something that we really do start to explore this season even
more that relationship their past and their future together
Wanted to ask a question about...was your friend, okay with that answer?
[I] want to see the face of the [know] I wanna see really see the [Frenchman's] yeah
I have a question about um the olympian Crystal
Yeah, okay um
Wins Elena shove it into hades. He was completely obliterated [my] [God] does know more
When hades shot Robin his spirit seemed to float away, but the body remained well
You know first of all like it you know
Everything that was said about the olimpian crystal was was said by Hades. Hades said that stuff about the olympian crystal
I don't know he was. He's god of the underworld kind of lies
Can we trust him can we trust I would say in all seriousness
That's a question that [I] think you know some of our [characters] should and will ask
you know it's
Okay, I like that answer I
Should like that answer a show about hope
You know I would I wouldn't choose not to believe hades, but we'll find out did you hear that?
I'm doing what I can't up here everybody. I'm doing what I can
Hi, honey. What's your question?
Hi
I'm
Natalie from Devas inside Hi everybody
Hi, so my question is for Josh um
In the first season when David was quote-unquote
Married to Catherine he was wearing [a] [way] was cursed
[he] wore a wedding ring
but then when the curse was lifted
He never put one up back on
Why is that [cuz] it means it's the same person really come on
She's upset about an excellent point
celeste Josh
Answer it Josh. Yeah, what are you doing? I don't know no right right now, Joshua drops. Yeah
We're in the ring excellent getting an atom on the phone
I yeah, I don't know why I don't know why he hasn't done the ring. I guess that's a question for Eddie now
You know what let's put the ring on and then we don't have to worry about the ring on the ring is [coming] back
Thank you
How was your course - I'm sienna, and I'm from Toronto Canada, and you're adorable
and
My question is um when you found out you got the part what was your reaction?
for everybody
Yeah
cuteness
Guys, I guess
[I]
[resign] again, whoever wants to get in there, okay, when when when I
Found out that I got the part [I] completely freaked out I
Was I love the role from the moment? I saw it so when I found out that I [got] it I
Freaked out. [I] honestly did I think I was crying
Okay, me too
Quitting right now
[I] totally freaked out. I was walking the dog and I had a bag of something as you do when you walk the dog and
spoiler alert wasn't nice and
[walking] along my agent Gordon. [she] went once upon a time. We'll need to be on the show like
Don't know what the role is you probably wonder why I'm like Nom [alright], and so I said yes
I didn't even know what it was one of the best days of my life
Sorry, I can't hear you [I]
[mean] it's all right. It's like our friendship. You know ears hearing whatever I?
Yeah, well these guys called me and and you know said do you want to be part of the show and I loved them we?
Got to work together and lost and so it was just an immediate. Yes
Of course and just you know I love the show [and] I love the cast that was amazing very very happy yeah super excited
I freaked out too. Yeah
The phone Rang, and it was my agent
But I didn't know because she said hi is Regina there, and I said I'm sorry if wrong number
Regina and I said wrong number Lana you got the part I
Opened a bottle of champagne. Yeah, I can't beat that Story I
Was thrilled I love the script from the very start
I didn't think then all of us went into throes of panic because it was working on how I met your mother at the time
And I had to beg the Showrunner was of how I met your mother
to flip the last two episodes of the season in order for the schedule to work
So we went into crisis mode and then and then excitement vote so the champagne came after the crisis I?
was really like
No, I was absolutely provided because I cuz I obviously didn't think that anyone like I didn't think I'll be playing Captain Hook cuz you
Know traditionally sort of yeah, quite a bit older, so I was I was through. I'm very excited to go into leather pants
How I recall oh my dear
Hi, Ladies. How are you?
Hi, I'm Carrie, and I'm from Los Angeles thanks, and I'm her mom christy
By the way that is it is that a Mary Margaret and Emma?
Let me say [sad] is what I love about the show
You have to present a story for costumes that are iconic enough to wear yes. I love it bird on your shoulders genius though
Our question is on a show like this with so many intense scenes and frankly character deaths um
What goes into?
preparing for little scenes and getting into the right mind frame [uh]
for all of us oh um
do you wanna start?
understand see it depends on the
scene or the the day
you know um
I've died. What is it three or four times?
You did say you're good at surviving
but so sometimes there was one where
[hook] sacrificed himself as the Dark dark when he gets a man to stop him whenever I'm we know that was way harder
I mean yeah, there's like a really late night with some of those in service
that can be that can be a heart, but you sort of
Well, we're as a cast. We're all so comfortable with each other and trust each other so it's easy to work
[together] and sort of um
You know kind of failure that and get there, so it's with this cast. It's great. It's easy I
Think everybody's different for me
I try to use stuff that's really personal to make it feel as real as possible because otherwise you know
It doesn't have the depth of meaning. I guess you know so I
Try to kind of apply things in my life. It would be really hard to lose and
Find a way to kind of flush out [some] of those substitutions
Um I every scene is well. It's different and it requires different
preparation so
Some scenes you know you kind of need to stay a little more
Focused in quiet and centered and some when we have these big like hero moments when we're all in groups together. It's really nice
we have a lot of fun and and that's part of preparation it brings us all together and and
Yes, there's this story Regina story is so
Complex that using her life is is very beneficial?
just thinking about what she goes through and how that moves me and how that affects me and
and
like Jen [and] probably a lot of other actors
We do use personal life our personal life does health and just finding okay?
Have I been through a similar experience?
[that's] really helpful. [how] do you relate to this particular character of this experience and and how would you react?
Now you try to remember that time someone reached into your chest or ripped your heart
Mean it is district for everybody everybody has a [different] way of going through like
the guys have said and you know it all goes it all starts with the writing and script and we all have character histories and
Over six seasons these characters are so rich with you know different levels of emotion and different stories
So you just draw on that as much [as] you can
Ya know the same things. Yeah like you're saying well
that's one of the beauties of being this far into a series is you do have a history [that] you've lived and
experienced through this character, so you as much as I draw from my personal life as
Something else have said that yeah, you get to do that with your character now because we've spent so much time with them
So that's pretty cool
One thing that really helps me like the slides thinking about you know if I've got to get really emotional for a scene
I think about awful things that have happened to me and I'll sit in it, but if I you know TV
We shoot really really quickly
So you might not have a long time to really get somewhere emotionally, so if I need to expedite the situation
I'll find
Songs that really make people make me cry so I love to cry sometimes it's not a really good cry with a glass of wine
I've got certain song about [oh]
All by myself
So I've got like some real dark [songs]
I'll just sit in my chair and get in this horrible mood
And then go out there and take it this means so much I know your walker
It's my iPod that makes me like this let the tunes in the head music [is] really helpful
Well, I agree with you when in situations like that you try and pull from your personal life
But at this point. We're so far in the [show] that
We have all connections with [each] other and are so close as a caste that it's easy to
Work together to get to that emotional state
Yeah, so I like
Yes
Nice. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
okay, guys, so we've gotten to the point [where] we have to stop taking audience questions, but
What's your name um I'm Alexis, Alexis I?
Want Collin go home with you so could you come up here and get?
Please remember to feed him
Roderick you work clock
Yeah, how are you [gonna]? Do this now? See you didn't think it through? What are you going to do now?
He's a star with the right arm in danger for okay guys, so look
Thank you, Rebecca for doing that wonderful vocal stylings
Just because I'm about to ask the question I asked every year and [I'ma] keep asking to somebody does this for me [I]?
Need a musical episode of once upon a time
doggone it
We're all like look out [hill]. It should be Christmas. Let's do a Christmas
Musical episode of what's one time, and I will even come and sing jingle bells are what kind of doing let's do it
Everybody up here has musical talent. I want it. I need it
Why don't you want to say it nice things?
you